when my son was in his junior year I'd
always expressed that he wanted to go to
college so I started touring colleges
with him and seeing how expensive it was
and as a single mom you know I don't
have a lot of options a friend of mine
said you know Diana have this the store
I have a smoke shop I need somebody to
come help me put it together so I said
sure I'll come work for you part-time
within like a month he changed his mind
he said I want to sell the store I was
like well you can't sell the store
because I'm working here and I don't
want to work for someone else so can we
talk about maybe possibly me buying the
store I emptied up my savings account I
received a small loan from my parents
you know and customers would come in and
they would always ask do you guys give
cannabis here do you have you know what
do you have do you have any Edibles this
that so I started to educate myself on
what this beautiful plant did and lit
city was born
based here in the Columbia Heights
neighborhood of Washington DC lit city
is part of the district's thriving
gifting industry nine years ago the city
passed initiative 71 making it legal to
possess up to two ounces of marijuana
for personal use the law also created a
loophole allowing stores to gift their
customers small amounts of weed as long
as they also buy another item often at
an exorbitant price such as an 11 word
motivational speech for sixty dollars or
a ninety five dollar Spider-Man sticker
we came up with a banging recipe from
brownies we named the brownies ants
College fun Brownies so you leave a
donation you can take a brownie and it
became such a hit because I was like
this is my son's college fun brownies
and this is what's going to put my son
through college four years later my son
did graduate from Clark University in
Worcester Massachusetts any store can
get into the business of gifting weed no
license required making DC home to one
of the most vibrant cannabis markets in
the country gifting shops also happen to
be majority of black and Latino owned
since Congress has authority over DC's
local Affairs gifting is a way for the
city to circumvent a federal rule that
prevents it from legalizing the sale of
recreational weed as 21 states have done
since 2012. ironically this system
functions better than most regulated
cannabis markets because other than the
gift and gimmick weed is treated pretty
much like any other good that consumers
can just walk into a store and buy
meanwhile in States like California
recreational marijuana is so heavily
regulated that sellers are struggling to
turn a profit and many consumers would
rather buy in the black market because
prices are so high so what's the DC
government doing with a successful model
for recreational weed trying to shut it
down
I'm Terence white owner operator of
Michael DC I also serve as the chairman
of the I-71 committee we're a group of
business owners who want to see the
district do things right from a
compliance standpoint from a safety
standpoint and from a product standpoint
early 2000s 2002 I started working for
myself in the Real Estate Field two
thousand eight hours indicted on a
federal charge I pled guilty to mail
fraud Aiden in the bedroom as I spent my
19 months I became friends with other
guys who pled guilty or had cannabis
charges so it gave me motivation to
actually be in the space because of the
fact that black and brown people
basically it's okay for us to go to
prison but it's not okay to be business
owners and when I saw the opportunity
here in DC
um I went for it medical cannabis is
legal in DC but up until recently the
district had an onerous regulatory
system that capped the number of
dispensaries that were allowed to open
purveyors also had to pay an eight
thousand dollar application fee which
had to be renewed annually at a cost of
Sixteen thousand dollars gifting shops
make buying recreational weed so easy
and convenient that dispensaries barely
had any customers anyway so the
relationship with the police was always
good from the start what happened
unfortunate only was that a shop opened
up next to mine they didn't have you
know their their stuff in order they you
know they weren't I'm assuming paying
taxes I paid taxes I pay employee taxes
I have a business license a certificate
of occupancy so this other business
because they got rated I was also kind
of caught in the crossfire as well so
here you just have to be 21 years old
everything is done in a discreet Manner
and they leave and they're happy and
they don't have to you know announce to
the world what they're doing because you
know it's it's it's a personal choice
I've been rated by the police three
times however I was I was never
prosecuted arraigned or any of that so I
was able to conduct business you know
open up my shop like the next day or two
days later the U.S attorney's office for
the District of Columbia has declined to
prosecute almost everyone arrested at
gifting shops but a new Bill signed by
the mayor in January will impose ten
thousand dollar fines on any store found
gifting and twenty thousand dollars if
they do it again these stores can also
have their business licenses revoked the
bill will also Empower DC to find
commercial landlords who rent space to
gifting shops Greg wimsat and Damien
West are the co-owners of Mr Nice Guys a
gifting shop with four locations in DC
their stores have been rated six times
and they've been arrested and released
without charges three times the trouble
often starts with a burglary attempt the
reason why we have bars on these windows
we've actually had it where we get
robbed our security system calls the
police not only we have broken our
storefront we have to deal with the
police instead of helping us the
antagonize they'll get a search warrant
and take everything take everything and
I'm just coming down here to secure the
location so I opened the door it was
already a cop inside they can drag me in
tell him you know Beat It
and lock me up they came in early one
morning and they took all of the day's
worth of merchandise they took all my
CBD products which was very
disheartening because CD is very
expensive they took cannabis destroyed
the door obviously they had to come in I
wasn't gonna go as from
I mean I understood what was going on
and I also understood that I am doing
business in a gray area so it was like
you know just know my place
they oh we're preventing a gray Market
business or you're a great Market
business so I'm like technically every
marijuana entity in the United States is
a gray Market business because it's
federally illegal you get to do all
these little play these little games
with them to be able to operate business
so the police say it's a great Market
business but I'm just as much as a gray
Market business as the medical business
that has a license if the gifting shops
get shut down will DC residents still be
able to get their weed legally or will
they go back to buying on the black
market although the Mayors recently
passed law will lift the cap on the
number of dispensaries allowed in the
district to obtain a medical license
store owners will still face significant
red tape for one thing applicants will
have to prove to the newly created
alcoholic beverage and cannabis
Administration that there's enough
consumer demand for marijuana in a
particular neighborhood before they can
open their doors the bill also grants
the agency the discretion to reinstate a
cap after one year gifting shops May
apply for one of the new licenses but
doing so means taking a big risk
according to the new bill if their
applications are denied they'll be
ordered to shut down within 30 days
medical dispense
Grace reader is the former executive
director of the I-71 committee she says
that many DC area residents would never
consider patronizing a dispensary
essentially they claim the reason
they're not doing well is because of
these gifting stores instead of
addressing the root causes of the issue
which is a city like DCU with so many
federal employees don't want to register
for a government database that says they
need medical cannabis especially when it
impacts a security clearance or other
things unlike gifting shops anyone who
wants to buy from a medical dispensary
has to register in a government database
which could create problems for the DC
area's 200 000 federal employees that's
really where the gifting stores come in
is you know there's a lot of people who
don't want to say I use medical cannabis
federal law technically prohibits
medical marijuana users from buying a
gun or living in federally assisted
public housing though since the passage
of I-71 the DC Housing Authority hasn't
evicted anyone on these grounds I fight
back for those who don't have a voice a
lot of return citizens feel like we
don't have a voice
70 some percent the same numbers that
reflect from 2014 are in favor of us
staying open so why would you rate US
the fact that Council continues to try
to write legislation to shut our doors
or to enforce it's crazy imagine that
Georgetown student who indulges in
cannabis now she has to go to the
7-Eleven or a street dealer and she
doesn't know what she's getting those
are the things that I fear
this is the reason I try to keep our
doors open there's a danger that DC will
become more like California where the
illicit market for weed is now twice as
large as the legal one licensing regimes
can also be discriminatory whether
intentionally or not Washington state
has granted 558 recreational Cannabis
licenses and four percent went to Black
applicants and when people come into the
I-71 stores and they get whether it's
Marco or lit City or what whomever
regular experience they get what they
pay for and that's what you want you
want people to say hey man
this is dope
this is hot I I feel the energy and when
people leave reviews they talk about the
customer service but they talk about the
experience that gifting experience was
great and I think as a whole and as I
continue to Advocate that's things I
advocate for let's take the stigma and
Stitch it doesn't have to be sterile
because it's a culture it's the Earth
it's the apparel it's music it's the
culture of canvas the last thing I want
is to close my doors you know I don't
want to have to submit an application
and wait to see what happens and are
they going to approve me you know and if
I do get approved what does that mean
for my for my store for my customers
does that mean that I'm not I'm gonna
have to take people with a medical
license to come in here you know I have
employees that have families to feed you
know I have to pay rent I don't want to
have to go through all of that I want to
be able to still serve the entire
Community as I've been serving them till
now